hi i'm chris flannery a senior fellow of
the claremont institute
contributing editor of the claremont
review of books and host of the american
story podcast
every generation of americans from the
beginning
has had to answer for itself the
question
how should we live our answers
generation after generation in war and
peace
in good times and bad times in small
things and in great things
through the whole range of human affairs
are the essential threads of the larger
american story
there is an infinite variety of these
smaller american stories that shed light
on the moral and political reality of
american life
and we keep creating them
these fundamental experiences known to
all human beings
but known to us in an american way
create the mystic
chords of memory that bind us together
as a people
and are the necessary beginnings of any
human wisdom
we might hope to find these mystic
chords stretched not only from
battlefields and patriot graves
but from back roads schoolyards and bar
stools
city halls blues joints summer
afternoons
old neighborhoods ballparks and deserted
beaches from everywhere you find
americans being and becoming
american a story may be tragic
complicated or hilarious but if it is a
true american story
it will be impossible to read or listen
to it attentively without awakening the
better angels of our nature
so here's one about the beautiful
friendship of two remarkable americans
i call it fingertip memories helen
keller was 14 years old
when she first met the world famous mark
twain in 1894
they became fast friends he helped
arrange for her to go to college at
radcliffe
where she graduated in 1904 the first
deaf and blind person in the world to
earn a bachelor of arts degree
she learned to read english french
german
and latin in braille and went on to
become
practically as world famous as her dear
friend
writing prolifically and lecturing
across the country and around the world
twain with his usual understatement
called her
one of the two most remarkable people in
the 19th century
his other candidate was napoleon
i guess he forgot lincoln keller lived
into the 1960s
and shared some of her fond memories of
twain in an autobiographical book she
published in 1929.
in particular she records recollections
from her last visit to her friend
in his stormfield home in reading
connecticut
which she thought of as in her words a
land of enchantment
she preserves for us a vivid image not
only of mark twain
mr clemons as she called him but of her
own vivacious mind
about twain she writes there are writers
who belong to the history of their
nation's literature
mark twain is one of them when we think
of great americans
we think of him he incorporated the age
he lived in
to me he symbolizes the pioneer
qualities
the large free unconventional humorous
point of view
of men who sail new seas and blaze new
trails through the wilderness
they gathered around the hearth one
night after dinner at stormfield
she records mr clemens stood with us
back to the fire talking to us
there he stood our mark twain
our american our humorist
the embodiment of our country
he seems to have absorbed all america
into himself
the great mississippi river seems
forever flowing
flowing through his speech
when twain took her to her room to say
good night
he said i would find cigars
and a thermos bottle with scotch whiskey
or bourbon if i preferred it in the
bathroom
one evening twain offered to read to her
from his short story eve's diary
she was delighted and he asked how
should we arrange it
she said oh you will read aloud and my
teacher will spell
your words into my hand
he murmured i had thought you would read
my lips
so that's what she did upon request and
as promised
twain put on his oxford robe the
gorgeous
scarlet robe he had worn when oxford
university conferred upon him
the degree of doctor of letters
here is keller's recollection of the
evening
mr clemons sat in his great armchair
dressed in his white surge suit the
flaming scarlet robe draping his
shoulders
and his white hair gleaming and
glistening in the light of the lamp
which shone down on his head in one hand
he held eve's diary
in a glorious red cover in the other
hand he held his pipe
i sat down near him in a little chair my
elbow on the arm of his chair
so that my fingers could rest lightly
on his lips
everything went smoothly for a time but
twain's gesticulation
soon began to confuse things and so a
new setting was arranged
mrs macy came and sat beside me and
spilled the words into my right hand
well i looked at mr clemens with my left
touching his face and hands and the book
following his gestures
and every changing expression
killer reflected that to one hampered
and circumscribed as i am
it was a wonderful experience to have a
friend like mr clemons
i recall many talks with him about human
affairs
he never made me feel that my opinions
were worthless
he knew that we do not think with our
ears and eyes
and that our capacity for thought is not
measured by five senses
he kept me always in mind when we talked
and he treated me like a competent human
being
that is why i loved him
there was about him the air of one who
had suffered greatly
whenever i touched his face his
expression was sad
even when he was telling a funny story
he smiled not with his mouth but with
his mind
a gesture of the soul rather than of the
face
his voice was truly wonderful to my
touch
it was deep resonant he had the power of
modulating it so as to suggest the most
delicate shades of meaning
and he spoke so deliberately that i
could get almost every word with my
fingers on his lips
ah how sweet and poignant the memory of
his soft
slow speech playing over my listening
fingers
his words seemed to take strange lovely
shapes on my hands
his own hands were wonderfully mobile
and changeable under the influence of
emotions
it has been said that life has treated
me harshly
and sometimes i have complained in my
heart because many pleasures of human
experience have been withheld from me
but when i recollect the treasure of
friendship that has been bestowed upon
me
i withdraw all charges against life
if much has been denied me much
very much has been given me so long as
the memory of certain beloved friends
lives in my heart
i shall say that life is good when helen
keller left the enchanted land of
stormfield on that visit
she wondered if she would ever see her
friend again and she didn't
it was 1909 and clemens would live just
one year more
but she writes for us in my fingertips
was grave in the image of his dear face
with this halo of shining white hair
and in my memory his drawling marvelous
voice
will always vibrate
so that's fingertip memories and
here's another one about an american
whose name the whole world knows
john wayne
22 year old marion morrison known to his
friends as duke
was carrying a table on his head across
the sound stage of a john ford movie
he was working as a prop man in a fox
studio in la early in 1930.
director rao walsh was looking for a
leading man for an epic western he was
developing
about a great wagon train journeying
across vast deserts
and mountains to california
walsh didn't want a known star to play
the lead
he was looking for someone who would in
his words be a true
replica of the pioneer type
he didn't want the audience to see a
part being acted
he wanted them to see the real thing
again in his words
someone to get out there and act natural
be himself
then he happened upon the young duke
morrison lugging the table
across the sound stage and here's walsh
recalling that
he was in his early twenties and
laughing
the expression on his face was so warm
and wholesome
that i stopped and watched i noticed the
fine physique of the boy
his careless strength the grace of his
movements
what i needed was a feeling of honesty
of sincerity
and he had it within a few weeks
after a quick screen test duke would be
signed up for the part of breck
coleman the fearless young scout
in an ambitious film to be called the
big trail
he would more than double his income
from 35 dollars to 75 dollars a week
he had to let his hair grow long and
learn to throw a knife
and he would have a new name john wayne
already as the young frontiersman in the
big trail
the man the world would come to know as
john wayne is recognizable
he is more athletic and beautiful than
we remember him from his later pictures
and he has a sweetness and shyness of
youth that recedes over time
but he is tough and in charge he has a
natural air of command
the widescreen film is still visually
stunning and interesting to watch
but it was an epic flop and left wayne
languishing in b-movie purgatory for
almost a decade
before john ford decided to make him a
star
as the ringo kid and the great western
stagecoach
ford was inspired by something similar
to ral walsh's inspiration when he chose
duke morrison for the big trail
these are four's words it isn't enough
for an actor to look the part
and say his lines well something else
has to come across to audiences
something which no director can instill
or create
the quality of being a real man
ford added that wayne was the only
person i could think of at the time
who could personify great strength and
determination
without talking much
that sounds easy says ford but it's not
either you have it or you don't
john wayne had it as james baldwin wrote
one does not go to see katherine hepburn
or betty davis
humphrey bogart or john wayne act
one goes to watch them be
and duke morrison decided that john
wayne would be the kind of man
he and the audience wanted to believe in
whatever his flaws and wayne's
characters had many
he would present on screen a character
that had something admirable in it
this character certainly added
dimensions with his great films like red
river
the searchers but his essence was
discernible from the earliest days
he had courage and self-reliance
obstinacy
and even ruthlessness but also
generosity of soul
and spirit as his biographer scott ayman
put it
he had the kind of spirit that makes
firemen rush into a burning building
because it's the right thing to do he
had
humor gusto irascibility
he was bold defiant ambitious
heedless of consequences occasionally
mistaken
primarily alone larger than life
as one of wayne's colleagues said john
wayne was what every young boy
wants to be like and what every old man
wishes he had been
wayne was 32 when he made stagecoach and
69 when he made his last film
the shootest in that film he plays the
dying gunfighter
dying gunfighter john bernard books
his oft quoted line from that film would
been right at home in the big trail
i won't be wronged i won't be insulted
i won't be laid a hand on i don't do
these things to other people
and i require the same from them
for 25 years from 1949 to 1974
wayne was among the top 10 box office
stars every year but won
and he was more than a star for his time
well under the 21st century 35 years
after his death
he was still listed as one of america's
five favorite movie stars
he became indivisibly associated with
america itself
in hyman's words on his 72nd birthday
may 26 1979 as wayne lay dying of cancer
in ucla medical center
the united states congress in a
unanimous bipartisan vote
approved an order signed by president
jimmy carter
for striking a congressional gold medal
in his honor
wayne would be the 85th recipient of the
medal
the first recipient was george
washington
winston churchill was awarded the medal
just a few years before john wayne
as president carter said wayne's
ruggedness
the tough independence the sense of
personal conviction and courage
on and off the screen reflected the best
of our national character
wayne's friend actress maureen o'hara
testifying before congress
said to the people of the world
john wayne is not just an actor and a
very fine actor
john wayne is the united states of
america
he is what they believe it to be he is
what they hope it will be
and he is what they hope it will always
be
so that's a john wayne story and here's
one about an american whose name it
won't be as familiar to you probably
but you will uh you'll want to know it i
hope it's called
we are all americans
eli parker was born in 1828 to elizabeth
and william parker
of the tonawanda seneca tribe of the
iroquois confederacy in western new york
parker became a leader in his tribe at a
very young age
trained as a civil engineer and earned
himself a reputation in that field
in 1857 when he was 29 years old
he moved to galena illinois as a civil
engineer
working for the treasury department and
there his life took a fateful turn
he became friends with a fellow named
ulysses s grant
in these years grant was an ex-army
officer working as a clerk in his
father's store
parker later liked to tell the story of
coming to grant's aid
in a bar room fight angelina the two of
them
back to back fighting their way out
against practically all the other
patrons
at about five feet eight inches and 200
pounds
the robust parker referred to himself as
a
savage jack falstaff
when the civil war came on parker
several times
tried to join the union army as an
engineer but was turned down because he
was not a citizen
when he approached secretary of state
william seward about a commission
he was told the war was an affair
between white men
that he should go home we will settle
our own troubles among ourselves without
any indian aid
thank you very much
eventually with grant's endorsement
parker received a commission with the
rank of captain
as assistant adjutant general for
volunteers
by late 1863 he had been transferred to
grant's staff as military secretary
he soon became familiarly known as the
indian at headquarters
and was promoted to lieutenant colonel
and later to brigadier general
he may have saved grant's life or at
least prevented his capture on a night
in the wilderness campaign in 1864
when grant and his staff were riding
into enemy lines in the dark
unbeknownst to themselves but parker is
rightly most remembered
for something that happened in the
parlor of a private residence
in the village of appomattox courthouse
on april 9
1865.
in the days preceding union armies had
captured the city of petersburg
and the confederate capital of richmond
grant
and the federal army of the potomac had
put confederate general robert e
lee and the army of northern virginia in
such a position that in the late
afternoon of april 7th
grant sitting on the veranda of his
hotel headquarters in farmville
said to a couple of his generals i have
a great mind to summon lee
to surrender he immediately wrote a
letter respectfully invitingly to
surrender
and had it sent to him under a flag of
truce
it took lee a couple of days of
desperate failed maneuvers
to come around the idea but by the
morning of april 9th
lee had concluded and these are his
words
that there is nothing left me to do but
to go and see
general grant and i would rather die a
thousand deaths
they agreed to meet in the village of
athematics courthouse to discuss
terms grant had been rioting hard for
days on rough roads and rough weather
when he met lee in the parlor of the
brick house where they had arranged to
meet
he had on dirty boots an old suit
without his sword
and without any distinguishing mark of
rank
except the shoulder straps of a
lieutenant general on a woolen blouse
lee was decked out from head to toe in
all the military finery he had at his
disposal
after introductions and not much small
talk
lee asked grant on what terms he would
receive the surrender of lee's army
grant told him all officers and men
would be paroled
and disqualified from taking up arms
again until properly exchanged
and all arms ammunition and supplies
were to be delivered up as captured
property
lee said those were the terms he
expected and he asked grant to commit
them to writing which he did
on the spot and showed them to lee
with minor revisions we accepted and
grant handed the document to a senior
adjutant general theodore bowers
to put into ink in grant's words
this was a document that would
effectively put an end to four years of
devastating civil war
bowers hands were so unsteady from
nerves
that he had to start over three or four
times
going through several sheets of paper in
a failed effort to prepare a fair copy
for the signatures of the generals so
grant
asked eli parker to do it which he did
without trouble this gave occasion for
lee and parker to be introduced
when lee recognized that parker was an
american indian
he said i'm glad to see one real
american here
parker shook his hand and replied we are
all americans
the american story is still young and is
already
the greatest story ever written by human
hands and minds
it is a story of freedom the likes of
which the world had never seen
it is endlessly interesting and
instructive
and will continue unfolding in word
indeed as long as there are americans
the stories i think are most important
are those about what it is that makes
america beautiful
what it is that makes america good and
therefore worthy of love
only in this light i think can we see
clearly
what it is that might make america
better and more beautiful
thank you